Alexis there appears to be this sort of
you want to call it class warfare going
on in crowdfunding these celebrity
crowdfunders versus the die-hard indie
filmmakers the DIY people and there's a
lot of talk about how the celebrities
should not be allowed to be on these
crowdfunding platforms that somehow it's
taking money away or notoriety away from
the smaller little guys quote unquote
what are your thoughts on this well I
should preface this by saying that I'm
no expert on crowdfunding I was
associate producer on a short film that
did a very small amount of crowdfunding
but I have heard about and of course I I
follow the film courage website so I do
hear about these things but I had heard
about one particular celebrity getting
crowd funded and there's this kind of
there's an inevitability about
celebrities using it because everybody
everybody's trying to get a little bit
of extra publicity there's no guarantee
publicity do you not I mean publicity is
made by people it's the journalists that
if they're interested how did you get
them interested you know these folks are
overworked and they're trying to get
stuff in for a deadline and the trommel
look for the idea and they want to
please their editor and it's like oh
such and such is the first celebrity to
use a crowdfunding website bingo and of
course the clever celebrity or their PR
person is going to know that it's a
bingo and it's going to happen so
there's an inevitability to this at the
same time is is some of this going on
because the celebrities need the money I
that might sound odd but I think there's
this false idea that you kind of you
struggle you stronger you stronger you
stronger you make it ah so easy now and
I'm no celebrity but I know people
who've got further than me and the
struggle struggle and it's it's always
an effort every new project is a new
effort you know you every day is a day
when I feel like Michael Douglas of Wall
Street you got to get up ready to bite
the SRM air now every day is a day
when you've you've gotta move forward
you know if I'm not promoting my brand
if I'm not if I don't have projects
running then you know if one of the most
tempting things I'm kind of diverging a
bit but this is it raises an interesting
point and it's something that I i think
i may have put in the article on film
courage if not it was so it came soon
after i wrote that article about play
your cards right and it's this idea that
are right i did that everybody liked it
I'm that's great you know I've had some
press attention everybody's admitted I'm
an artist now so they can't stop saying
they can't they've got to say I'm an
artist you know they called me a
composer and etc or they can call me a
filmic I've done that so I can relax and
just enjoy the the achievement now it's
true you need to relax and need to enjoy
yourself but I I always I know that if I
stopped doing what I'm doing and pushing
things forward and coming up with new
projects not just working on the old
ones were coming up with new ones that I
would lose momentum for a start and
people would perceive me differently as
time went on it and it would become it
would be my intuition I'm really thought
this through my intuition I can just see
myself slowly you know talking about
that rocket love the imagined rocket it
would be just a slow sinking down of
myself both inside in my self belief as
an artist and in terms of people you
know where I work because but bear in
mind as I set up I have a salary you
know I'm there I have a job title at a
job description and part of that is
these there being an artist and people's
perception of me there would sink down
and gradually I'd become more and more
of a scientist and which is no nothing
wrong guy I if I wasn't a scientist I'd
go mental you know it wasn't an artist
I'd go mad so that's one of the things
you know and I'm sure that's the same
for everyone you know I'm sure no matter
what degree of
success you have is you can't have you
know have much money you have much
success you have you're always going to
be I want the next thing I want the next
thing the people aren't like that okay
would be happy on 30,000 a year as happy
as they were on you know 30 million a
year slight exaggeration that you see my
point there are you know most people we
desire is not fulfilled by getting what
we want desire is a thing in itself and
just fulfilling the first desire desire
will remain and there don't be a new
thing in it and there'll be a new thing
and there'll be a new thing so it's a
rather deep philosophical answer for a
question about crowdfunding and
celebrities and I'm sure there is this
this element of just taking advantage of
the publicity but I also think you know
that maybe the people that think
celebrities shouldn't use this I mean
you shouldn't use that Avenue some of
them may be a thinking that when they've
made it that they won't need to use that
Avenue the idea we have this deep desire
I think that will get to a certain point
in our lives and will have made it and
we can relax and just enjoy something to
keep on struggling and I don't think
that's true but that may be some of the
psychology behind people that saying
celebrity shouldn't use crowdfunding
because maybe they have a dream at the
back of their mind that when they become
a celebrity they'll have reached that
point where they can relax and after
struggling more so they won't need
crowdfunding you know they won't need to
take advantage of every possible Avenue
available to get the next projects off
the ground but I believe that no matter
how successful how rich you become the
next project will always be a struggle
so I think I mean having said that I
don't depend on crowdfunding so it's
very easy for me to give that answer if
I was depending on crowdfunding then it
would be to my advantage to fight off
the bigger fish though like given a
contradiction to everything I say but
there is one thing it may seem that by
stopping celebrities using crowdfunding
that you're saving more for yourself you
know if you depend on crowdfunding to
which which I don't they
then you want you'd say well I want to
keep the celebrities out they keep the
bigger fish out there but there is
another side to that which is that
crowdfunding you know it has two sides
it's like trading you know you have a
seller and a bias so you're selling
something and you want the crowd of
buyers to come in and to give you
funding the size of that crowd has a
large impact on whether you reach your
goal or not how many people knew about
things like IndieGoGo and so forth
before a celebrity comes in if a
celebrity comes in and it gets broadly
publicized that such-and-such a site has
been used by this celebrity you gotta
wonder if maybe you know ten percent of
the people that read about it maybe
might even go online and look at this
website a website they were never looked
at otherwise and maybe a proportion of
them might see your project you know
maybe a portion of them might start
searching through see multiple projects
and maybe more money will come in so
there is a question which I don't think
we have time to do the cost-benefit
analysis now but celebrities could well
bring more buyers to the market they
obviously they may suck up some of those
buyers so i think it's an unresolved
issue but i do think some of it is
probably driven by this this idea
celebrities somehow in some protected
position and and they're not you know
there and they've got a fight every day
to keep their career going
you